hi martin i'm working on a design doc
um do you have a few minutes to help me
with it yeah i
love design sessions great
okay we have these on-prem servers and
our new developers keep
building new things which is great
but um i'm thinking i need some kind of
web application to help me manage it all
that and some batch processing to keep
track of the state of things
okay this new application sounds like a
good use case for serverless
let's get started
high level we want to make sure they go
through the proper approval process
before launching a new service
and frankly it's getting difficult to
keep track of everything
i want to build an application that
helps me
manage open ports on the servers keeps a
log for our auditors
and allows developers to easily file
requests for opening up
access for new applications we have
three distinct users
um we have a developer an admin and an
auditor and the developer should be able
to
make requests for new open ports
through a web application and the admin
should be able to approve those requests
the admin should also get notified if
there are ever any open ports
that um he did not approve and then the
auditor should be able to see just the
entire logs
of all the things that have been open um
at any time
oh cool sounds good so we have them here
we started our system diagram
and down in the lower right hand corner
we put the servers that they're
monitoring
this is a company internal app is that
right
yeah it's completely internal oh got it
so
they are employees they should be able
to reach it but
no other external users
should be able to reach this application
exactly
what might we put in there to make it
easy to keep employees in and everybody
else out
um i think like another thing to
consider is like first of all it's only
internal employees but also
these two employees have different
permissions and different roles of the
things that they can do
so it should be something that allows us
to kind of like
you know tweak and tune the the
permissions levels
oh that's a good point developers and
admins can do different things yeah
so i'm thinking then identity aware
proxy here
uh backed by app engine it's really easy
to put
iap and app engine together you think
that would work here
yeah no i think that would work great um
okay so
then app engine with little iap in front
of it
controls like who can get in okay so but
now we need to
to we need to think about storage
because
they are going to be making requests and
approving requests so that means that
like we need to be able to create read
update delete some kind of something
um and to me the big question is do we
use
nosql or sql so we're trying to keep it
serverless
um which would
mean no sequel uh and i'm also thinking
uh there won't be too many reports of we
won't do too many aggregations like
averages and sums
and and stuff like that right i think
like just like thinking about like how
the people are interacting with the data
and also like how i would model the data
um no sql is really feeling like the
right direction because
they're they're not gonna have to do
like you know big reports and
even when you think about like we have a
server the server is you know
represented by like
the ip address and then we have a set of
ports underneath it so if
i were to have a document and a nosql
database the document the id
would be the ip address and then
we'd have the list of ports in it as
rows
and then you know whether or not it
should be open oh yeah it's kind of
hierarchical like that
yeah i agree so yeah let's go for nosql
firestore is great and serverless so
it'll go very well together with the
other serverless components here
each document i guess would be a server
and and as you said underneath it has
ports and
permissions and things for our auditor
and also for just our peace of mind
um we want to write a little port
scanner so that
we can we can check we can check that
all the ports that are open are the ones
that have been approved
and i want this to happen nightly
and i don't like i don't want any
interaction okay so nobody goes in and
clicks
and says scan the ports right now okay
got it
yeah like a cron job oh i don't i don't
want the cron job on my computer
yeah yeah yeah and dina closes her
laptop and goes on vacation and no
current jobs are running
yeah so uh right and of course the way
to run cron jobs
uh in in google cloud platform is cloud
scheduler i think that would be a great
choice here
we can set it to run nightly change it
to an hourly whatever
and then and then this would the cloud
scheduler would need
to call something what kind of component
should it call i wonder
so like thinking of like the
functionality that we want what we want
to do
is we want to have the
the ip address and we want to
attempt to make a request to connect to
every single port on the ip address so
you know we're thinking of like
nested for loops yeah which actually
sounds really scary oh my gosh
um but the first thing that we need to
do is
we need to get the list of ip addresses
so
maybe maybe we can like break up this
functionality
a little bit and have the like the first
function just
call to firestore and and get that list
of ip addresses oh
i really like that yeah so okay so that
first function is really simple like you
said it just gets all the records
uh and does no port scanning on itself
okay so
no nested for loop here uh but that one
is just pulling out
the the data and now who does the actual
work
that's a really great question because
we we really want
i don't want it to just like call
another function because then we have
the problem of the nested for loops
and if you're you know going through the
tens of thousands of maybe millions of
ports like something's gonna break
and it's gonna take a really long time
and then what are you gonna do just like
restart the whole thing
so yeah right
i'd really like to do like some kind of
like
asynchronous like fan out kind of
something or you said asynchronous when
you say asynchronous dina
that makes me think of pub sub so
would it work if the orchestration
function published one like one
pops up message for every server and
then we had those messages
trigger different cloud function that
tested just one server each
that is so good that's like even better
than like like what i was originally
thinking because
because what that allows us to do
then is like if um if our function fails
for some reason right
then we only have to retry that one
port on that one server and we don't
have to worry about the hundreds of
thousands or millions of other ports
um it's just the one yeah right so it
doesn't get stuck
no timeouts okay this is really good so
the poor tester then
gets just one server that each test or
maybe one server and one port
combination it tests that so it's a
really simple function
uh now it needs to put the data
somewhere um
and i'm especially looking over there to
the left at where it says admin
the admin should get an email whenever a
port is open that shouldn't be open
right how do we how do we get that data
over there into that email
right so i think then what we need is
when we
get to the support tester cloud function
like we're feeding in the ip address
the port and whether or not it should be
open and then we're receiving back
the the response of like true false it
was open
and so then we want all of these four
pieces of data
to um especially like if
if it doesn't match like if it's open
and it shouldn't be open or if it's not
open and it should be open
because that can happen too then we want
that
to trigger an email
but also we want everything not just the
things that
don't match we want everything to go to
the auditor
and so i think
i think maybe we're going to do like
another pub sub thing oh right
because and i think the reason that this
fits very well is when you said this
data goes to two places
pubsub is amazing for that right you
publish it once and then you can have
multiple subscribers
yes yes multiple subscribers and we can
do we can do a
filtered subscription so then our little
function doesn't have to do any logic
it doesn't have to like say like hey you
know if else you know this
go here go here we're just sending
everything to pub sub and then
we can have our filtered subscription
that um will pick up
what whenever like the the match thing
doesn't happen you know
and that can trigger an email oh right
right yep yep
so we have that filter subscription
could go into app engine
app engine has that little logic little
handler in there that whenever it gets
one of these messages it does what you
just described
it calls an an email api sends an email
cool
so we have that dangling thing down
there the auditor looks a little lonely
in the
lower left hand corner how do we get
data
to uh to them right um okay so let's
let's work backwards a little bit yes um
[Music]
the auditor is going to want to look at
like a report
maybe like in a dashboard and when i
think about you know dashboards
i start thinking about sql like you
you want to be able to like write
queries so we should be
storing this data in in some
in something that has like kind of like
a sql interface and
i'm thinking because we're just like
appending rows and it's going to be a
lot of data
i'm thinking i'm thinking bigquery might
be a good option i really like that yeah
yeah because this is exactly what
bigquery is for right
reporting uh and yeah so
we just put a little cloud function in
there that is triggered
so i guess this one would not be a
filtered subscription it would be a
regular old subscription right
yeah yeah everything we want everything
and the auditor wants to see it all
cool all right very nice so now we have
auditor
once a web page the data is in bigquery
already this is great
now but we need that web page and
bigquery to meet here somewhere
uh i mean should we sit down and write
the web app
and figure out some library that can
draw graphs and things
no i don't want to do that i've done it
on so many projects
i really don't want to do it either yeah
okay um
i'm gonna throw this out there i think
we should use data studio because like
when you're looking at bigquery there's
already a button that's like hey look at
this data in data studio so there we go
easy
i i like the way you think because now a
business analyst could draw the charts
in data studio a developer can focus on
the other pieces of this
um and yeah no more building yet another
web app that draws charts somebody has
already done it for us
awesome this looks so good okay um let
me just walk through it real quick make
sure
i have it all um i think i have enough
for my design doc but let's let's go
through it
okay so for our web app we're going to
have app engine
and we're going to have identity aware
proxy iap
to control our permissions and we're
going to store all like the requests
in firestore and then every night
um for our audit we are going to have
cloud scheduler
basically kick off this like pipeline of
pub sub and functions that ultimately is
going to scan
all of our ports and we're gonna write
all of the results to pub sub
and we're gonna have a filtered
subscription
that sends the bad results um
back to app engine and we're gonna
trigger an email to our admin and then
we have all the results going into
bigquery which we are going to show
the reports in data studio yeah i really
like it i think this flow would work
well
uh this would actually this would be a
fun application to build yeah
i i i want to start building this cloud
scheduler thing right now it looks
awesome
yeah yeah my brain is tingling
awesome i love these design sessions
thank you everyone for watching
this is how you might build a serverless
based systems everything you saw here
was serverless if you have any questions
for dean army about anything you saw
in this video or if you have a request
for us for other types of application
you'd
like to see us do design sessions for
please add them in the comments below
until next time bye
you